- We always wanna wrap up the hour
with something that makes
you feel all warm and fuzzy.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
So during a trip to Ghana,
an Atlanta teacher visited a local school.
She was shocked at what she saw.
Students had to share notebooks.
They didn't even have a
bathroom in the building.
The roof was in such disrepair.
Kids would get rained on.
So she sprung into action,
at first just helping get them resources.
Then she straight up
sold everything she owned
and moved to Africa to
build schools full-time
because she's an amazing human.
Let's get this amazing
educator on the line right now.
Hi Brittany.
(audience cherring)
- Hi
- My Gosh.
So this is a huge life shift, right?
- It's been crazy.
It's honestly been so crazy
and I just feel so grateful.
It's been amazing.
So I went to Ghana to visit schools
and I love to visit schools on vacation.
And I was just so shocked
at what I saw when I went
that I just felt so inclined
to help out as I could.
And very quickly I rallied
up like my Instagram family,
my family at home,
and I was able to fundraise
about $6,000 in six days
and get six computers for the kids
as well as completely
build a computer lab up
from the ground.
- Wow.
- And it was just really good.
It's kinda going the
global education, you know,
globalization connect with
other kids around the world.
And it was just really amazing.
- No, I mean the opportunity
that you just gave those kids was just
with being able to be online
and educate themselves.
That's a, it's an amazing
thing and build that for them.
Now you're living in
Africa full time, right?
And you have big plans.
So, how's it going?
How are your plans going?
- It was great.
So when I did get back to Atlanta
I continued teaching for a while
and something just didn't
really feel right with me.
And I just felt really
inclined to do more.
My dad has always told us
as God continues to bless
us, we bless others.
So I called on my Instagram family again
and they came through
and I was able to completely move myself
and go with supplies
for the school as well.
We fundraise money
to help them completely
top for their building.
And right now I'm
actually working in Kenya
as an international school teacher
and saving up to be able to
open my own all girls school
in a proper for K-12 girls.
And hopefully be able to see
them off to college as well.
- Oh my gosh.
If you, this is not lip service.
If you ever need help,
please contact my show.
I would love to help you out.
I think that's a beautiful
thing that you're doing
and you know, kids,
they don't know anybody
they're just born, right?
It's like, we need to be
able to have opportunity
for all these kids born
to be able to shine
and do whatever they dream of.
And I think that that's the
coolest thing that you're doing
for them and putting your life
and being so on hold
and being so selfless.
It's such an angelic thing.
And if you ever need help,
please, please let us know.
Thank you so much, Brittany.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
That's not all though.
Our season long partner,
Pilot pen, makers of
friXion-the go to a erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show wanna celebrate
those creating fearlessly,
just like you ma'am.
So they're gonna give you a $1000.
How's that sound?
(audience clapping)
- Oh my God.
Thank you so much.
- All right.
And I'm not kidding.
Please, let me know if I
can help you out at all.
I think what you're doing
is a very very cool thing
and very beautiful.